money aside so like like a Hummer aside
how much of a motivator's fear
it's a big one you know uh I I I'll say
I you know for me like I didn't I didn't
think I was gonna lift this E30
and I was sure of it did that concept
scare you or was that just a principle
of life you're operating under uh
I lost my brother when I was uh 13 on it
too like you know he was 19. uh he was
like the uh
the VIP of the family you know
you miss them all every day uh he was a
you know he was a you know
skateboarded BMX uh motorcycle Hunter
one of the best marksmen that I've ever
seen shoot so better than you and
everything yeah he was the best of us is
what we would say and uh when he died
there was a there was it was almost like
a concert at this funeral you know I met
three of his girlfriends that all
introduced themselves like the the one
you know yeah uh to this day every now
and then I get uh pulled aside down when
I go back home and uh they uh hey you're
Eric's Eric's brother you know despite
all the stuff that I've done I'm still
you know every now and then I get
recognized
um
that made my mom and my dad go into a
horrible depression and basically you
know left me to my devices when I was a
kid
um from 13 onwards
I had this self-destructive you know
aspect to me after that I think you know
so again something that's come up in
therapy you know after I've been gone
through all that
uh and had this notion that if I can
only die good in some way shape or form
or for something that it would it would
matter and they would kind of you know
look at me with the same reverence I did
with my brother
so dying
isn't the problem the goal of life is to
die for something good yeah at least
that was my
that was my mindset going through that
job uh I remember
I was in medical school before that you
know second year of medical school I was
doing pretty good and then 9 11 happened
and you know that wasn't an option
anymore for me the economy was horrible
couldn't afford to stay there so
I saw this ad in the newspaper and my
brothers my big brother who's still
alive and had to uh he's like
you know yeah you're not gonna do that
[ __ ] you know we wouldn't dare
and all of a sudden I was in a field
having my hair shaved off and a bunch of
the uh
Gophers the guys that later turned into
the Zeta cartel uh military men were in
charge of our training you know and I
went through that process in what field
were you and why is your head being
shaved and what the hell was going
through your mind what was the leap that
you took I was sold the idea of this
being a new Americanized police force
that they were constructing in Mexico in
Mexico
so Elite
yeah Special Force kind of prestigious
Elite uh the people in charge of our
training were a lot basically uh X
Mexican Godfather people Gophers are
what the Special Forces kind of
originated a lot of their members turned
into the uh The Zeta cartel so they were
brutal in their training we were sold
this idea of it being you know
scientific uh edu like educate educated
based and like a career path and all of
a sudden we're in this uh
refurbished prison that wasn't good
enough to be in prison and they turned
it into a training ground
and I quickly kind of realized that they
were training us to be a paramilitary
group not a not a community policing
organization which in my mind that's I
thought that's what we're going to be
doing what was the hardest process of
that training for you because this is
like a
a fragile innocent boy becomes a man
kind of process it's it's uh they're
turning us into something that they
could use so it's a breaking noun
uh they break down the individual you
know it's uh physically and mentally
yeah I think it's a
H it's a it's a half done initiation
process I think in a way you know
looking at it from now to the past the
uh
the Shaving of the hair the uh the
stripping off your identity you know
everybody gets a
gets a number
um the uniforms the
running around and
and uh you know being treated like human
garbage the first thing they said to us
when we were lined up in that field was
uh
which means uh there's bread and Dick to
eat here and the bread ran out a week
ago right so
it was I mean I can't equate it to
anything in the military in the United
States because people down there could
actually get physical with us I mean
they could actually pit us and punch us
and [ __ ] like that which is
not allowed here anymore at least in in
in most of the militaries and is
horrible as down there
uh AK-47s being shot around us to to
simulate reality basically causing
hearing loss that type of stuff
um so chaos
uh abuse really challenging you yeah
again physically and mentally and an
Open Door there always so if you don't
want to be here you can just walk out
and the more you go into it time wise
you're more invested you are so
in a way you're kind of building your
own chains while you're going through
that process well you're tempted to walk
out yeah several times several times uh
specifically seeing some of the ways
that uh
people that I thought were better
or stronger than me were walking out or
quitting uh because of something that
happened in there
was some sexual assault stuff happening
in there as well are you afraid of that
ball is you know you're in a place like
that and there's females in the in the
environment and some of the instructors
are doing what they do
so that was like a cause for alarm I
mean these people are in charge of our
safety and education and look at what's
happening here so you could see some of
the the smarter ones leaving you know
not not looking at this as a viable
choice for Life how did that change you
that uh those few months
I had this motivation this idealistic
motivation in my head you know of making
a difference and
they drill uh uh they drill a lot of uh
nationalistic kind of uh you know the
flag marching
it uh being part of a group and the
group being you know behind you and all
this what was the nationalistic pride it
was it in the nation of Mexico yeah yeah
so what's the vision of this great
nation of Mexico that you were did you
believe did it get into your blood it
got into my I mean it's an
indoctrination you know it's a it's a
paramilitary group so everything there
is basically modeled after after the
military uh so that's what they were
trying to kind of instill in US
I was a
I was a team leader in there after three
months basically I was
um
we went through a bunch of Trials
physical trials um and mental trials and
stuff like that and some of us were
named team leaders
and I you know bought into it you know
I'm the uh
I'm supposed to be here look at me I'm
I'm making headways I'm I'm uh
I'm sticking out a bit you know
and uh I was pretty proud of what I was
going through there uh six months
then you get the reality check when you
sign the dotted line and how that none
of it really meant anything as far as
what we were about to go out and do you
know
uh
an example of this we were trained with
a 92 FS Beretta which is a nine
millimeter pistol uh Italian made
we got to shoot 20 rounds out of that
gun
and then we when we got out we were
handed a Glock uh 17 which
um I've never seen one in my life
I was uh trying to figure out where the
safety was and
a few other people there were uh
handling those guns in a horrible manner
um
uh so we were very under trained under
equipped then there was a lot of
assumptions about what we knew and all
of a sudden we were being cast into this
the in the start of one of the
you know bloodiest and longest lived
modern conflicts uh in our history that
doesn't get called that but it's it's
basically been an ongoing war in Mexico
that uh
that is still to this day you know
amassing bodies so the Mexican drug war
the Mexican drug war which is
you know it's hard to pinpoint exactly
when it started because when I was going
through training there was already stuff
going on I went into training in 2004
and then we're already you know
major cartel related events all over
Mexico by then but not at the at the
size or scope as I was about to go into
you know when uh
president Felipe Calderon kind of took
office down there and actually
officially kind of kicked it off by
putting the military in play as part of
uh as part of it basically militarized
the uh the drug war you know including
us